i
meses
ya
[Aplausos]
unidos unidos venceremos divididos
caeremos es la frase que fue utilizada
en la segunda guerra mundial
fue utilizada por los aliados cuando
decidieron combatir al eje del mal que
estaba dividido por los italianos por
los alemanes por los japoneses y años
después nosotros tendríamos nuestra
venganza contra ellos cuando decidimos
ponerle capture para la pizza cuando
decidimos ponerle filadelfia al sushi y
perfeccionamos la salchicha alemana
cuando la convertimos en salt y pulpos
de nada mundo de nada unidos venceremos
divididos que haremos es la fuerza que
fue utilizada para crear unión y
comprensión en el mundo porque cuando el
mundo se une para hacer cosas increíbles
no sale bien padre como friday es por
twitter esta organización que estaba
alertando nos de este problema que
tenemos que es el calentamiento global o
que me dicen cuando juega la selección
mexicana
todos nos ponen una playera una playera
o casos más difíciles como cuando
decidimos romper el récord guinness de
gente bailando thriller igual por
mexicanos de nada mundo de nuevo
pero algo hay algo que nos une más y es
el odio nos encanta odiar nos han fijado
siempre vamos buscando maneras
diferentes de odiar ya sea porque eres
el final de game of thrones o
eres el papá luis miguel existe mucho
daño tu hijo
físico o no le dijiste a tus hermanos
donde es el cadáver de tu papá
y les voy a presentar a mi amiga el
acordeón porque no hay palabras que que
son difíciles porque deciden si hay o
qué
nos encanta odiar y en méjico
o te gusta el fútbol o le vas a la
américa no hay de dos o sea la gente en
serio se aprende muchísimo y siempre
están como atacando el américa
los estadios se abarrotan no para ver
ganar a su equipo sino para ver perder
al américa
así de grueso digamos y es uno de los
temas que quiero platicar el día de hoy
la virtud de la poderosísima sala ser
que no es cierto es cierto no es cierto
vengo hablando de polarización
polarización política y hace por
definición la polarización es esto
posturas extremas en ideologías pero no
se preocupen mucha gente ya debe estar
muy asustada creyendo que voy a hacer
como testigo de jehova a tocar la puerta
a decirles que tienen que pensar en que
no ya existe el pan no me interesa mucho
hacerles eso
pero hay que darse porque al final hay
fotos de ejércitos con lentes de humano
todavía no
existen dos tipos de polarización la de
élite y la masiva la de élite se refiere
los ideales de la gente y perdón de los
partidos y la de masiva se refiere los
ideales de la gente pero actualmente
estamos viviendo una combinación muy
bizarra de esas dos porque los partidos
políticos no se han fijado se están
robando los ideales de la gente para
conseguir votos y eso es nuestro peor
más adelante si lo que es lo peor de
todo eso
la polarización política viene de una
falacia lógica conocida como falso
dilema en el cual se presenta una
situación y nomás se van a presentar dos
opciones como las únicas que existen
dejando atrás a terceras cuartas
opciones que podrían resolver este
problema pero las ignoramos normalmente
estas dos posturas que tienen son
extremas voy a poner el ejemplo muy
claro voy a un restaurante y les
pregunto qué de comer me dicen hay dos
cosas está esta lechuga que la isla la
cultivaron niños triquis básicamente y
te va a dar diarrea o tenemos la
hamburguesa que se llama tap arterias
que está muy rica deliciosa si te quita
dos años de expectativas de vida pero
pues qué más quién quiere vivir 80 años
y este se trata de esto porque la
polarización política es como el jonah
hill
de la política no conoce puntos medios
del señor
pero vamos con los ejemplos vamos a ver
qué está pasando en el mundo vamos con
el ejemplo más claro que es eeuu en eeuu
hay dos partidos políticos los
demócratas y los republicanos
y vivimos un tiempo donde obama con los
demócratas estuvieron a cargo y les fue
muy bien sin embargo los republicanos
tuvieron su venganza y ganó este señor
y así
donald trump gano polarizando su país
prometió borrar absolutamente todo lo
que hizo obama y lo hizo mientras estaba
montado en un águila ondeando la bandera
americana con un rifle en la mano
explotando el monterroso en esta foto
real no me pregunte como la conseguí
esta foto es real si usted pregunta si
eeuu dio un giro de 180 grados a su
política y si tu conoce a alguien que
dice que dio un giro a su vida 360
grados esta persona está en lo correcto
porque esa persona era tonta
dio una vuelta completa pudo un punto
que pudo haber sido inteligente y
regresó hacer tonta porque no existe ese
chiste me lo robó maldito pinte pacheco
gracias milton pero no pasa nada
vamos con otros casos del caso de brasil
brasilia
con lula da silva que era el presidente
de la izquierda y como que no les
funcionó mucho por lo tanto se fueron
con el extremo como el sónar o bolsonaro
pues el wifi es como si el blanco bailar
samba es un ejemplo perfecto permítanme
decirles
hombros con el caso del reino unido
reino unido
ay dios rey frío
el líder del partido de los
conservadores y persona que dejó abierta
la ventana del auto boris johnson esta
persona
dividió su país diciendo quiero sacar el
reino unido de la unión europea y esta
persona es primer ministro así está
pasando estas cosas en el mundo y méxico
ya saben cómo explicar cómo funcionan
las cosas pero algo que sí me gustaría
decir es que todos son extremos que nos
ha quedado claro eso todos son extremos
y no entendemos que todos los polos
extremos son peligrosos excepto el fuera
de eso todos son peligrosos aquí viene
mi primera pregunta no hayan serio qué
pasa con el pelo de boris johnson nos
aparece una naranja que acaba de
exprimir la dejan así eso parece
mi verdadera pregunta es cuál es el
verdadero peligro de la polarización
política
recordamos que hablamos de la
polarización elite y la polarización
masiva hablábamos de que estaban
consiguiendo votos estaban consiguiendo
gente para conseguir votos pero ese no
es el gran problema
se retiró muy fuerte porque le da mucho
coraje esto porque nos están dividiendo
en dos bandos señores nos están
dividiendo en dos bandos y no estamos
entendiendo qué está pasando porque
están tercos con eso nos quieren ver de
que si no es con esto es con el otro
entonces no estamos entendiendo cuáles
son las verdaderas que están entendiendo
el punto pero lo peor de todo es twitter
es twitter no se han fijado en twitter
con lo que quieras en twitter las
mandarinas son deliciosas no importa va
a llegar alguien a decirles a mantener
son delicados a mussolini le encantaba
las mandarinas que no te gusta malito
fascista así estamos
me pasó que les digo
cyrus y fish ricos pobres americanistas
fans de marta de baile
nos estamos insultando horrible ya
debemos dejar de insultar los señores
dios no se de acuerdo
trabajo hace unos guiones y uno de mis
programas principales se puso la
repubblica
muchas gracias gente que sí lee
y hemos visto fans de todo y hemos visto
gobiernos de todo el mundo visto
gobiernos de izquierda y los gobiernos
de derecha y más a peña nieto que era
pues como un niño con un control interno
desconectado
pero algo que me da mucho coraje porque
hemos visto todo tipo de promesas hemos
dado noticias que créeme sólo pasan en
mexico pero algo que nunca habíamos
visto era fans de políticos
mujer
como porque o sea en serio había visto
todo hasta el club de fans de hombres
heterosexuales de chayanne
informes conmigo apuntó conformes
conmigo cuando acabe esto
pero políticos como lo entiendo buscando
y lo hacían por una torta por un chasco
por un contrato por un puesto que les
sobren el gobierno pero actualmente ni
eso van a conseguir y chayanne sigue
atrás de mi verdad no importa sus
precios aunque puede aguantar
y cuál es el problema de stefan el
problema de que pierdan todo sentido de
la crítica y los van a defender no
importa lo que digan los van a defender
no importa lo que hagan aunque se
contradigan los van a defender a capa y
espada ahora sí ya tiemblen bien y los
medios que están haciendo los vídeos
para resolver esto
los medios
se están vistiendo con los colores de
los partidos
el medio o los medios deberían ser ese
árbitro que señala y observa lo que
hacen los jugadores o los partidos pero
muchos de estos árbitros o medios no
todos nos incluimos otros nombres
están siendo ese árbitro que le mete el
pie al jugador para que se caigan a su
equipo anda muy cabrón con mis analogías
deportivas no se dieron cuenta muy
cabrón como es una energía deportivas
lydia cacho dice
el periodismo debe ser esa linterna que
ilumine el mundo no un brazo derecho de
un partido político estoy muy de acuerdo
con ella porque antes presidencia decía
que se podía decir y que no en los
medios y actualmente gracias al internet
gracias a él la información lo
conseguimos más rápida más inmediata
esto no significa que sea de primera
calidad hay que estar muy atentos a eso
porque si hay muchos medios que se
dedican nada más a perjudicar a lo que
hace el presidente porque no les
conviene
al otro lado están los medios que se
dedican a no pegarle para nada al
presidente y hacer listas como quien es
el más guapo en el gabinete del
presidente ha pasado que me no voy a
decir nombres pero ahí estoy ahí
ambos están mal la verdad es que ambos
están mal y la respuesta a separar
aprendemos a leer entrelíneas señores
aprendamos
los medios muchos medios tienen una
razón por la cual están haciendo una
noticia no nos quedamos con una sola
idea o con un solo medio le damos varios
aprovechemos que tenemos todo el
internet para hacerlo
y no quiero ni empezar con las pequeños
está más que comprobado que los partidos
políticos están metiendo su agenda en
internet y en los medios para perjudicar
al contrario
pero bueno ahora sí 2040 que está
pasando bueno se lo voy a poner así si
usted cree que después de este gobierno
y aprendimos con la izquierda usted es
joven usted es muy joven tiene un
segundo
plazo para la izquierda porque tardaron
mucho y no se van a ir tan fácil créanme
no se van a ir tan fácil van a pedir una
segunda oportunidad así como se la dimos
al pan en el 2006 con calderón o cuando
el dimos una segunda oportunidad del pri
durante 80 años porque no somos muy
inteligentes tampoco
y luego
a venir a la derecha ahora si después de
ese sexenio viene a la derecha pero ya
no cualquier derecha señores ahora viene
una derecha radical aprendamos qué está
pasando en brasil aprendemos en otros
países tienen la derecha radical una
derecha con de mayúscula que va a ver va
a servir a trump a calderón y al papá
como nos pone así va a ser los ver de
ese nivel
y por qué hacemos eso
porque en méxico no votamos por el mejor
candidato votamos para castigar al otro
partido es lo que hacemos y hay mil
ejemplos de que lo hemos hecho cuando
castigamos al primo votando por fox
cuando castigamos al pan votando por
peña cuando casi vamos al planeta no
aprendemos pues dando por habló le hemos
hecho constantes que se llama voto de
castigo es un término real
no lo inventé yo no es como que veo
pero no todo está perdido señores en
serio
después de pasar esos dos extremos puede
venir a la tercera alternativa una
alternativa que tengan promesas más
reales que sea con ideas más aterrizadas
aportando no empujando al partido que no
le conviene porque tenemos que vivir
esta realidad de que no tenemos muchas
opciones y no de que casarnos con las
ideologías hay que casarnos con las
ideas es diferente porque lo que
queremos es mejorar a méxico
y al principio no le vamos a prestar
atención a esa persona desgraciadamente
no lo vamos a
captar lo que está diciendo pero
si lo captamos puede que tenga una
tercera opción muy interesante una
cuarta opción para la quinta opción las
ideas nuevas bienvenidas sean
y si usted está diciendo ya entendí se
está lanzando no no
aunque para 2030 y se llamará venas
canas poca madre usted sólo pierden no
pasa nada
pero no mi trabajo es muy divertido y es
aventar le tomates a los candidatos los
que están allá arriba no me interesa lo
más mínimo recibirlos workers quería
hacer mi trabajo están con los medios y
espero que cuando sea el momento me
toque señalarlo o señalar la no sabemos
cuando sea el momento estamos hartos de
focas aplaudidoras hartos en serio
pero bueno en resumen
si esto no entendió nada no se preocupe
yo tampoco méxico es una chica guapa ok
y tiene dos galanes uno es muy fresa
pero muy bien saben controlador y el
otro es un white and hippie que need and
legalismo completamente bueno también
está el priísta que la mano aquí a
llevar al motel pero no lo pelamos mucho
últimamente
y es que amiga mexica
está peleando de reyes y no estemos
viendo como bobos eso y no se vale
porque tenemos que darnos cuenta que
estamos divididos los únicos que ganan
son ellos
porque la división vende la polarización
vende y los únicos que pagan somos
nosotros y no se vale
porque bueno esto va para los partidos
amigos de la derecha
no existe un peligro para méxico gméxico
y amigos de izquierda izquierda
no hay una mafia del poder entienden
y acabe por último por último les voy a
dejar con una frase de la periodista y
columnista paul davis que dice cuando
los partidos empiezan a hablar de grupos
grandes de personas como enemigos hay
que estar alertas señores porque la
polarización es un buen medio para
conseguir votos y ganar las elecciones
pero también lo es para llevar un país a
la ruina mi nombre osvaldo casares y
como lo prometí fotos de gatitos con
lentes
[Aplausos]